ah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh the return on investment I have been
to many meetings and network clubs and
masterminds and organizations or spoke
to property investors and they know even
now to calculate the return on
investment if you don't know how to
calculate the return on investment you
are not a professional property investor
you just not so what is the return on
investment when I'm buying a house
there's only two figures number one not
even the rent
he's the two figures number one is what
am I putting in ie
how much money and I not how much am I
blind hands for how much cash and I
personally putting into the deal that's
number one number two is how much am I
getting out what that means is how much
profit have I either made or am I making
on an ongoing basis so if I buy the
house for two hundred and then right now
how much of my own money am I gonna have
to put down how much am I gonna be
getting as an income and then once
you've got those two figures but this
would be annual income this would be
total investment or what the damn this
is total investment and then this is
annual income and then what you're gonna
do is you're going to divide these
figures together so you're going to go
your annual income divided by total
investment equals x times that figure by
a hundred that will give you your are oh
I that's the only figure you care about
you